cosa importa se
viviamo in mozambico mettiamo insieme io
sono greta e tu alberico sito il nostro
salve richiamarlo che piega caso mentre
vi racconto della mia vita
i ragazzi benvenuti questo video siamo
tornati su rocket league parlo della mia
vita come se non ci fosse un domani
questo format che sto portato ma molto
noi facciamo drillo solo che agiamo
trillo lo fa molto più meno family
friendly che commentiamo così io invece
ho notato questa cosa in live perché io
gioco a rocket league
magari se vi faccio vedere gli impieghi
di te ecco e avviato che no perché
magari senza le imprese come è difficile
vedere che non sono facendo quindi
dicevo il live
l'ultima volta che ho fatto live è
uscito fuori che quando gioca rocket
league mi viene automatico parlare della
mia vita perché io e 3 euro kg che ci
gioco del divertita pincher e legamenti
fatti mi girano le balle quando perdo
però mi diverto a parlare con voi ce lo
faccio anche quando gioco con i miei
amici e roche trio parlo con loro di
cose private quindi adesso punto ha
detto perché non facciamo anche in video
questa cosa così la gente si fa i cazzi
miei da mentre che io tento di segnare
nella porta avversaria una cosa molto
carina
oggi parliamo di un argomento molto
molto privato cose che io non dovrei
dire su youtube perché teoricamente le
cose private giorno essere privata oggi
parliamo di un argomento un po e cioè
nel senso sono molto a disagio in realtà
nel dirlo se devo professore sincero
però è uno dei primi video così devo
sforzarmi e quindi ci proviamo e vediamo
se esce fuori
allora io sono una persona molto
timida a particole presupposto che io in
tutte le storie che racconterò compresa
questa non parlerò assolutamente dicendo
nomi reali di persone tranne se le
conoscete anche voi tipo tipo pietro non
parlerò dicendo i nomi reali di persone
perché io faccio le cagate le cagate e
poi faccio questo mi sant otto persone
cioè io nella mia vita non ho capito
niente cioè non sono anche come
spiegarmi questa cosa
comunque dice in questo caso si tratta
da come avrete capito dal titolo della
prima volta senso parliamo di questa
cosa come se niente fosse
anche se per me è molto difficile ci
credo che sia più che altro in modo per
aprirmi al pubblico visto che io non è
così semplice parlare di cose private
perché mi sembra un po come se avessi
appena iniziato a rifare il primo video
e è una cosa bella ma allo stesso tempo
è difficile quindi mi scuso con voi
ragazzi la mia prima ragazza che oggi
chiameremo santina siamo stati insieme
per più di un anno
insomma un anno eravamo molto felici io
ero molto timido tra l'altro il mio
primo bacio l'ho dato a lei c'è il mio
primo vero bacio lathan ora c'è stata
un'altra volta c'è stato un bacino ma
smancerie ovvero marcelo dato a lei
ed è stato molto difficile nel senso che
molte volte ci penso mi gridano le ossa
perché dico cavolo tipo 20 minuti per
tornarci questa persona era seduta dopo
che siamo usciti insieme la prima volta
la seduta su questa panchina
e io ero tipo ok lo so devo darmi un
bacio perché l'ha votato anche un micro
regalino stupido pochi euro io sono
sempre tirchio che aspettavo che io le
tele del sim bacio solo video su una
visione ovviamente timida quindi non
riuscivo a darle cristo è stato molto
kring in a come come situazione e allora
si è messa ad aspettarlo io che mi
cagato addosso mi caga mo veramente
addosso sono rimasto a fissare il vuoto
per un po di tempo perché avevo paura
nel fare questo bacio fino a che dopo un
quarto d'ora di tempo lei ha chiuso gli
occhi della serie dai muoviti stare
anche guardando brutto pirla e io
facendo passare altri 15 minuti quindi
totale una mezz'oretta la fine
sull'uscita dare questo bacio con questa
persona poi abbiamo siamo diventati più
insomma più intimi anche perché ci siamo
conosciuti un po meglio è stato molto
molto divertente anche perché essendo le
prime esperienze po come quando guardi
una serie tv e se alla stagione uno che
dice e finissimo però la prima volta e
sempre a prima volta quindi il tutto
quindi tutto li fai le prime passeggiate
primi baci e la prima volta
quella prima volta che pensate voi
allora eravamo a casa mia non so come
spiegare questa cosa è molto difficile
allora premessa bisogna farlo protetti
per evitare referti cit ghali giorno
dopo corato primo bacio tra l'altro
perfetto quando ha raccontato alla mia
mamma mamma guarda che ho dato il primo
bacio ci ho messo mezz'ora a mia madre
ha detto che il figlio mi è uscito fuori
mio dio però era contenta il giorno dopo
il giorno dopo per il mio compleanno mio
diciottesimo compleanno è rotta e mia
mamma
quel giorno lì mischia fa sulla
scrivania quello che mia madre non sia
guardando questo video se stai guardando
questo video per favore mamma mandami un
messaggio scrivendomi ho visto questo
video così so come imbarazzarmi ancora
di più mia mamma mischia fa sulla
scrivania un pacchetto vi fa tutto quel
discorso che si fa della serie b devi
stare attento anche le imbarazzata
perchè io ho l'imbarazzo da qualcuno
l'avrà preso penso sia lei che padre
neanche si approccia questi discorsi
proprio non l'ho mai sentito io non ho
mai sentito fare niente siamo arrivati
dopo che stavamo insieme già da mesi
parlavamo già intimi entrambi non
avevamo mai fatto questa cosa arriva il
momento in cui succede
insomma i cui arrivi a quel momento
facciamo iniziavano il discorso è che io
sono il momento clou sono molto emotivo
e timido questo che però significa
significa che il mio cervello che se non
nei momenti più in generale il mio
cervello controlla 99 per cento delle
mie azioni cosa intendo quest'anno del
cervello intendo che se il mio cervello
si autoconvince di una cosa il mio corpo
si irrigidisce tutto tranne una cosa
quindi il discorso è questo che io più
penso meno agis così come sono molto
timido sono molto insicuro di me quella
volta lì è successo che eravamo lì e nel
momento del della situazione non mi
funzionava più
ecco come funziona più perché è diciamo
allora questa una cosa molto scientifica
il sangue per sempre funziona per far
funzionare
insomma tutto serve sangue ok siccome
mio sangue era totalmente al cervello
non ne avevo abbastanza per farlo
confluire in un altro punto quindi non
funzionava più c'è nel senso proprio non
c'era verso anche con il magnetismo non
andava giù ceram verso quindi sono stato
siamo stati un ora è qualcosa a tentare
di parere
rianimazione però non c'era verso io
quella sera lì dopo tutto questo tempo
mi ricordo che mamma mia quanto cliniche
stanno già visto per dire di quello che
mi misi a piangere io piansi quella
volta lì io piace mi sono messo a
piangere ci hai capito ma poi piangere
una situazione del genere cioè io sono
ho pianto piantano santina è stata molto
gentile anzi lei ci è rimasta stupita in
positivo che mi misi a piangere c'è
perché forse ha capito in quel momento
che io questo ci fosse capito già prima
che io ero veramente interessato a lei
però in quel momento in cui capisci che
hai questa ansia significa che tu non
sei al cento per cento concentrato sul
su questa persona e non su te stesso
quindi ciò vuol dire che nel male i ratt
era una cosa positiva però diciamo che
quella prima volta è stato problematico
in realtà questo problema non è successo
solo quella volta lì però è diciamo che
le prime volte in generale sono sempre
problematiche per questo io non potrei
mai essere quel tipo di persona perché
sarebbe un alzabandiera fallito ogni
volta quindi io cerco di poche ma buone
insomma basta questa è stata la mia
prima non volta in realtà perché poi non
è successo poi dopo siccome la prima
volta che ho fatto la figura così di
kakà dopo siamo riusciti cioè nel senso
più altri altro giorno c'era un'altra
maglia siamo riusciti santina però è
stato molto molto dolce
comunque io ve l'ho raccontato io non so
con che criterio caricherò questo video
comunque ragazzi questo è il racconto di
oggi
io so che vi sia piaciuto più a voi che
a santina insomma lasciato un bel like
lasciatemi un commento fatemi sapere se
volete altri video del genere da
sfigatello insomma e io con molto
rammarico magari prova portarveli magari
da temi anche nei commenti il
suggerimento di che cosa vorreste nei
prossimi episodi di sta roba che magari
vi racconta sennò vede racconto io
comunque rocket league mi ispira
raccontare robe non so perché allora vi
sia piaciuto ragazzo al momento vi piace
anche vari social convinto tanto
schizzare censis chiedetevi come sempre
ci vediamo al prossimo video per a
ragazzi
[Musica]